[Music]
lance bass playfully calls out justin
timberlake
and justin hilariously claps back
of course it all started when lance
pranked his former nsync bandmates
chris kirkpatrick jc chazi and
joey fatone facetiming them only to tell
them he was too busy to talk
uh hey man i'm sorry i'm i am so busy
right now
there's no way i can talk i'm at dinner
so uh can i call you back later
i'm so sorry guys i am so busy right now
i can't talk but uh can you call me
later
yeah just call me later i can't talk
right now sorry guys
hey joey oh look i cannot speak right
now i'm so busy can i call you back
later actually call me back later okay
but when the 42 year old performer
called
well this happened
[Music]
what the [ __ ] okay so he didn't answer
lance's facetime
but justin who shares two sons
six-year-old silas and one-year-old
phineas with his wife jessica biel
did slide into the comments of his
instaposts to explain
writing quote once those babies show up
you're unavailability will all make
sense bro
along with three laughing crying emojis
and the reason i wanted to get married
to this guy is
i know he'll be an amazing dad and we've
been putting off for a long time but uh
this is the year that we're actually
starting the process so
uh we're excited lance and his hubby
michael turchin are currently expecting
boy girl twins via surrogate so he
responded to justin's comment writing
simply
touche but it didn't stop there lance
later hit up tick-tock to continue the
playful jabs
calling out justin for being bad at
responding to texts
one more time
he captioned the clip quote it's the
little things
[Music]
back in 2020 lance opened up about his
journey to parenthood
revealing that his surrogate was eight
weeks pregnant with a baby boy
in 2019 but lost the pregnancy to
miscarriage
it was their ninth round of ivf our game
plan
was to you know do the ivf and have our
kids
and then be able to adopt you know the
next ones
um now we might have to switch that you
know so if this doesn't work this next
time
we'll just go ahead and go ahead and
adopt we're totally fine with that we're
we want to do that and back in 2020
lance told et that the nsync group text
chain
is all baby talk all the time what was
the last thing that you guys talked
about in the instinct
group chat it's all about babies at the
time justin and jess had just welcomed
their second child into the world
and apparently justin was responding to
his texts
have you had a chance to say
congratulations at all
well of course yeah we uh i've talked
very you know several times and of
course uh
we knew it before anyone else did so
yeah we've uh
it's been a fun celebration and they're
they're very very happy